hello and welcome to the shooky science
show where in this video i had a great
conversation with fadim gladyshev
professor at harvard medical school
where his research ranges from aging
lifespan control rejuvenation to
selenium and redox biology
we dig deeper into these different areas
in this video
so hi vadim thank you so much for
joining me today and yeah welcome to the
science show
yeah thank you for inviting me it's
great yeah i i watched a couple of
episodes and really enjoyed it so
thank you thank you
um so yeah i've read a lot of your
research um both your research articles
and your review articles and i just
thought i'd start with
a really interesting concept that you
mentioned in a review article which is
that you describe aging as being akin to
gravity it's a fundamental force that
can't truly be reversed and so i was
just wondering if that's still your
your understanding of aging and whether
or not you could elaborate on that a bit
more
sure
it's nice that you found this metaphor
because it was already published
uh eight years ago i guess
yeah so i still think this way but
this metaphor of course was meant to
distinguish aging and lifespan control
because often things are mixed up and
when they
find a gene that affects lifespan for
example if we knock out or express the
gene and affects lifespan we kind of say
it it kind of defines aging i think it's
not it defines lifespan and aging is a
kind of a different i would say
orthogonal kind of direction in that
space
so and that's that's what i meant yeah
by this metaphor meaning that uh the
agent would pick variant of gravity so
there are different question questions
whether organism ages or not and how
long it leads there's a two completely
different questions in my mind
okay and so i guess on from this um a
lot of your work now has are focused on
trying to talk about biological age and
actually trying to quantify aging and so
um what what does it mean to actually
quantify age and what do you think are
like the the best approaches to do so
yeah that's a very nice question so a
difficult one actually
so
yeah because
there's no consensus on what aging is
yeah so apparently
scientists in the field
video scientists they feel differently
about the aging process when we say we
quantify aging
also they mean different things so some
some people think when you find for
example functional decline and some
people think
think of quantifying a chance of dying
you know the
the change in the chance of dying over
time some people think about like damage
accumulation
so
and
to me um
these are still of course
in a way
questions that have been studied in my
mind my thinking is that the essence of
aging is damage uh more broadly
age-related negative consequences of
being alive
i i put it sometimes this way
and
and then
kind of integrative parameters of that
uh features of that like mortality for
example or functional decline is the
consequence of of damage accumulation
and sometimes they go hand-in-hand
and sometimes they do not so in a way i
think uh aging is
is not well represented for example by
mortality so it's uh of course
i i would say i'm saying very you know
maybe extreme uh
extreme things but there are in in the
field there's all this
you know um
body of work that involves you know
comforts equation and all of this
various mathematical models evolutionary
models but then and they all kind of
link to mortality
but when if you look at the mortality in
more detail we see that it's
very
you know sometimes very unusual patterns
so for example if you look at the human
mortality uh initially it decreases like
after a person is born it decreases
it has a minimum at the age of nine
and then it has uh
it stops increasing at the age of 20
especially in males and then after maybe
25 30 it increases again and so
evolutionary biologists you know kind of
fail to explain it in in a in a good way
because they say well we should not come
of course they say we should not
consider uh development because it's not
aging and then we should not consider
age between 20 and 25 because it's a
hormones and then uh they say uh
you know there's uh like
negligibly senescent animals or like
negative senescence i i don't know what
negative senescence means you know how
for example if you look at the turtles
or some fishes mortality decreases his
age and and fecality increases
so but
does it mean that organisms become young
i don't think so i think they become
older but the mortality still decreases
what i mean is that uh
we need to distinguish these features of
aging so in humans when we uh look at
the late in late life or second half of
life
all of these features they uh
go in parallel mortality functional
decline you know fitness uh damage
accumulation and then therefore maybe in
some
way
they they may all be kind of used to
quantify aging but uh but early life
that they are not they they're clearly
different and so what is that aging
so and and that kind of leads to this
quantitative tools like a clocks if
shitty clocks get clocks is the best
tool in my mind that kind of can
integrate the aging process it's still
not perfect of course and there are
various blocks that measure various
aspects of aging it's just better than
what we had before and then with this
clocks epigenetic but also
transcriptomic and maybe some other
clocks we are able to address completely
new questions like for example when does
agent begin or uh what's the rate of
aging uh in individual tissues or how
can we target aging in in different
periods of life including development
all of these questions can can be at
least asked with these new tools and it
was not possible before in my mind
yeah that's a really good uh answer and
you can now just raise many questions
that i want to follow up on so i guess
the first one um you've alluded to these
like negligible senescence or organisms
that don't appear to age one of them
that i know you've researched is the
naked mole rats and you published a
paper i think at the end of last year
that showed you looked at the dna
methylation age of the bloods of naked
mole rats and whilst initially if you
look at the mortality rate they they
don't appear to age based on the
methylation you do still see this aging
so i guess um yeah could you elaborate
on the findings from this paper
and what that means for understanding
yeah the aging process
yeah
um well first there have been two papers
uh there is one paper that we published
in nature communications uh and then
another paper uh uh led t horowitz and
vera gorbanova in nature aging uh
basically
the same conclusions that um it is
possible to construct an epigenetic
clock and possible to quantify
genetic aging in the nick morad
and we kind of relate this to the
previous data from the shelley
buffenstein's lab that showing that
mortality of nick moretz does not
increase his age
and the reason we actually wanted to
to study this is exactly to to
begin addressing the questions of
whether neck morals age in the
literature it's often
we can find
a statement that
nick moratz they have
constant modality rate
constant mortality rate and therefore
they do not
age to me it's a very strange because
this is a mammal
so
mammal has
irreplaceable
cells and structures you know some life
cells like neurons or cardiomyocytes so
of course
they would they would age
and therefore
like skeleton with age you know their
eye and so there are many many elements
they must age because this is the way
the physiological physiology of mammals
is kind of evolved
therefore how how come they do not age
based on the mortality so but based on
this epigenetic clocks it seems like
they do age it's just
their mortality does not change and
that's exactly points to this challenge
of how we relate aging to mortality
exactly and i think it raises an
interesting question about
trying to distinguish aging versus like
just continued development or do you
think that there is a clear
distinguishment between the two
yeah i think that is very clear
so so what i think is
first
in my mind aging is not a continuous
development
so of course there are
various concepts in the field that that
suggest
the case evolutionary models for example
disposable soma hyper function theory
to me again aging is
is an avoidable consequence of being
alive
so we have a program like for example
developmental program there are certain
genes in that program that i needed
you know to support this program so if
we delete a gene let's say that is
involved in development development will
stop there are no such genes in aging so
we cannot delete a gene to stop aging or
over express a gene to stop aging so
and therefore in my mind uh let's say
during development there's a program
uh there's a it has a purpose that
program to
to basically
prepare a
competing in individual
and then
a fit individual and then
there is a
consequence of that is aging because
during development cells are
metabolically active they produce
by-products and other negative
consequences of metabolism
and
these features they accumulate and
that's what we quantify and define
as aging
so of course we
you know need to ask questions how this
this aging kind of molecular aging in a
way
would be related to organismal uh kind
of state
because it is possible
that for example uh damage increases and
therefore biological age based on the
clocks increases whereas the organism
becomes
you know increases fitness
you know
this is unresolved steel so i think
additional
questions need to be studied
at that stage but more at the state of
uh
like various phases of development
yeah that's really good answer and so in
terms of trying to address these
questions we need i guess good
experimental tools to be able to do so
and so that brings me back to the dna
methylation approaches and to the
publication that came out from your lab
last year the single cell age and how
you can you've now developed a tool that
enables you to
measure the age of a single cell and so
i was just wondering if you could talk a
bit more about that i know i've already
spoken with alex on this channel but
also maybe talk a bit about the kind of
the benefits of having a single cell age
as opposed to
bulk samples
yeah well i mean because i think you can
refer to your nice uh piece with alex
trap who who developed this as we call
it sch single cell
epigenetic aging clock
and uh so
he's the one who
kind of developed a constant and
developed the clock so i was just in the
office and kind of enjoying during the
process
so it's all the greatest goal to him
basically and uh
and but of course uh
you know the idea here is that aging you
know cell is the individual
unit of life therefore aging must happen
at the level of cells and we just wanted
to address that question so
when we analyze the bulk tissue uh age
of the bulk tissue it is possible that
uh maybe all cells
age
in a certain coordinated way or maybe
it's possible that you know some cells
don't age and some cells age very
rapidly and then we get some some
average
so
so what is it that's kind of the
questions that we want to address
and uh it is clear that it's both
so
that uh there are some cells aged more
rapidly some
not as rapidly but
they influence each other
and and kind of the whole system kind of
progresses and but of course it's just a
few study and
it's the very initial clock it needs to
be improved further maybe additional
approaches developed so we are
particularly thinking of going
multi-omics because currently
just uh dna methylation
but there's there are still technical
limitations just uh the third is very
low for small theomics currently
and
alternatives like ataxic also a taxi car
basic has not been really developed yet
in terms of the aging parameters which
is another kind of promising area anyway
so there i think there are many labs
currently working in this direction so
hopefully in the future
there will be something like uh
multi-tissue uh single cell multi-tissue
clocks
single-cell multi-or mixed flux and
maybe even multi-tissue plugs i don't
know
able to determine the age of the cells
based on maybe one or two omics
parameters but also
know information about the state of the
cell you know cell type and some other
physics of the cell based on some some
other omics like aromaship
exactly yeah i think that will give us
like another dimension of information to
understand
what's going on in the cell as well as
i'm like trying to correlate it with the
dna methylation age
and so one of the things i liked about
that paper was how you used it to look
at very early uh development
and kind of so
i guess validated your idea about this
grand theory that there seems to be this
rejuvenationist decline in biological
age very early on in development i say
what kind of processes need to happen
early in development that
what i like why why is the age going
down at this this point
yeah
so
how it happened in our case is that i've
been thinking that
about aging of germline or germline so
because this is this cells are alive so
i i suspect that they they would
accumulate damage and therefore
they would they would age but then how
come the next generation comes to the
you know starts at the same kind of low
low age so i i i
there's the contradiction here somehow
and i wasn't sure how to resolve and and
uh
and then two years ago i was at the
conference in moscow it was
bioinformatics conference and then uh
somebody was giving a talk on on the
philadelphic state uh in plants
uh it's an evolutionary model uh during
development uh where uh organisms
acquire uh a similar
a similar state called phylotypic state
for example at the level of vertebrates
they're quite different uh in in uh
gametes and the way ghanaians look our
zygotes look but engineering development
acquired is the common state called
phylogenic state and there's a
revolutionary model
called hourglass model
and uh and and then they look very
similar but very like uh
uh and then uh for example it would be
hard to distinguish i don't know like a
turtle embryo
at that stage from maybe a mouse embryo
and but then later of course they become
different again and so this this state
also is characterized by the expression
of the evolutionary oldest genes
uh also very low variance and gene
expression and i was kind of listening
to the attack token then while thinking
about aging and cellular
derives may be the same
actually of course
that talk was completely there was no
word aging at all there was a
development in plants but somehow
it just makes sense so i
and i i've never taken actual
developmental biology in my life as a
class so i went to my division chief and
he's a development biologist he gave me
the textbooks on developmental biology
so i started reading it so i learned
about what construction is and other
stages and so
and then
i you know i wrote this conceptual paper
published about a year ago
on the ground zero and uh we wanted
really to test this idea experimentally
and then uh
uh chaba kiribati who was a postdoc in
the lab he just very skillfully
was able to address this experimentally
by basically uh quintifying biological
age by using various uh clocks and kind
of following biological age as a
function of development and you could
see this basically all the clocks the
effect is very striking that uh the
zygote uh biological ah is not zero it's
quite low but not zero and then it
decreases so
the differences between this initial
conceptual model and the actual data
apparently i initially thought that the
age would decrease right away after
conception uh for example during like
initial stages of cleavage i thought
okay maybe it
would already be education but but it's
not at least based on this pepsini
clocks it stays more or less the same
and then it sharply drops later uh
already after implantation when uh like
approximately at the station august
relation
and then also alex trump uh applied his
sch
approach to
to
to study how biological age changes
during development and again we observe
the same thing
the biological age decreases
so
it's very
gratifying that you know you usually
kind of think about this idea and it
turns out to be correct of course it
still needs to be validated by other
labs i mean it's still possible that we
like like all this in science we can we
can never be hundred percent sure yeah
so we always have to be skeptical and it
would be good if some other labs test it
and validate or extend but if this is
true i i think it's very very important
because
this is the kind of the first natural
rejuvenation event somehow cells are at
a higher biological age and then they
decrease biological age so how do they
do it what's the mechanism is it related
to
uh ipsy nuclear programming uh this
monaka-like approach uh if
if especially if it's not then maybe
possible to find common features about
these two reprogramming processes and
this will allow us to better understand
uh
what is rejuvenation how can we maybe
apply similar strategies to somatic
cells
and so on i think the implications are
a very big if this is true
yeah for sure and it was really
interesting to hear your backstory to it
um it was really cool and so i guess
what what it demonstrates though is that
early development which i guess was kind
of already known as a very sensitive
time uh to changes and so
i mean
do you think that there's obviously
variations like even like within the
human population as to this very early
stage and how maybe
you know early development and slight
differences and how far the
reprogramming or the decrease in the age
goes
has an implication for like our total uh
lifespan
yeah that's also a good question of
course in this conceptual paper i
discussed this possibility that
that maybe they could interfere with the
rejuvenation process and perhaps
um
prove it further to basically to kind of
start aging at the lowest possible maybe
lower than that would naturally occurs
biological age
the idea exploring this idea but there's
no answer yet
and
and and of course it's also possible
that even if we decrease biological age
initially even to a lower level uh we
don't know whether it would actually
impact aging later in life we'd be not
sure because it would be like very low
or extremely low and if the for example
uh
damage accumulates at a similar rate
then this kind of difference will be
would be negligible later in life this
is also possible so
or maybe it would
just kind of stain in the same
trajectory it begins slower and continue
slower that's also possible
both are possibilities but we just don't
know the answer
but yes we are thinking about it how to
um kind of amplify it how to extend it
this this rejuvenation process
yeah that's a really good point but um
it kind of leads me on to a recent uh
preprint that's come out of your lab
that's treated
uh mice and then i think as well uh
daphne or dress of life can't quite
remember but um you treated uh
mice as soon as they were born with
rapamycin
um and what was seen so after this like
early um
intervention
with rapamycin you saw that it
influenced both the health plan and
lifespan and so i was just wondering i
mean one seems to validate your idea but
also because you elaborate a bit more
about what you found in this this
publication
yeah but this publication have actually
just because uh the analyzed lifespan
and it's it takes three years so of
course we started this way before that
and the reason we started is that uh
anatasia shinjapuna was a postdoc
fellow in the lab
she uh kind of approached me and with
this idea it was your idea she said
let's let's try reproducing durian
development i wasn't sure because we
haven't studied this before but somehow
she was able to convince me that it was
a good idea
and we were not sure for three years if
it would work or not and and later
and turns out to be that the lifespan is
extended so we're very happy about it
and then we uh also collaborated with
leon perkins lab at here at the
department of systems biology
who
on daphnia and they
basically have done
similar experiments with daphne and
found the same same thing that
treatment early life treatment with
rapamycin kind of delays growth uh and
and and eventually it extends lifespan
in both organisms what is interesting
there was another paper this actually
submitted to buy archive back to back
information that was i was conducted by
a lab in italy to help with uh omics
analysis and in the conversation we
realized that actually we have very
similar data uh so they also cheated
with uh urbanization early in life and
also extended lifespan what is nice that
in our case uh we used uh eugenie mice
which is uh it's a heterogeneous mice
cross of foreign red lines and they left
just used uh one in red line and we used
rapamycin in the food they injected
rapamycin we had like from zero to three
zero to forty five days and then they
had from zero to thirteen from thirty to
sixty so basically it's very
complimentary study so it's really nice
that
different models different feeding
procedures and they also have done it in
flies and we've done it in enough it's
just kind of very complimentary and the
same same findings all organisms so
we're very happy about it i think it
gives confidence that it's true
the findings are correct
yeah so uh but of course uh it has not
been reviewed yet it is peer reviewed
so now the paper has been submitted and
let's see what the reviewers will say
yes that's true
i guess one of the the striking findings
though is that uh the mice that were
treated early in development with
rapamycin um so breath myosin from the
audience you don't know it inhibits the
protein mtor and that's involved in
regulating cell growth but when the
young mice were treated for this short
time period it also caused them to be
smaller in general was that correct
so does that kind of come from the idea
that there does maybe seem to be some
trade-off between
um growth and
aging
yes it confirms but i think
ultimately growth is still one of the
characteristics i think it's not uh i
mean
we see many exceptions like nick moretz
for example as we discussed the uh
small animals but they live long
yeah so
yeah
i think there is connection but again so
i think it's just not one-to-one con
connection here
but uh also
like we could inhibit cell growth for
for various reasons
you know and
maybe some of them when we actually
truly develop the slow down uh the
development then you may extend lifespan
but we also make inhibit growth for
various reasons just would be really
damaging
and and therefore actually i spend might
be shorter in this case
yeah i see and that's why i think it's
good it kind of also relates for example
dwarfism so like in human there's a
dwarf but uh there are different types
of dwarfism some morph is associated
with
maybe extended health span and
potentially lifespan and some are not
and i think as well you saw uh
sex-dependent differences that it seemed
to um have a stronger effect on the male
mice and the female mice
yeah but we always observe this with
many interventions in mice
so
it's just in the itb program for example
but uh
many interventions that they tested and
the majority of them
the majority of interventions that
extend lifespan they actually extend
less than primarily males and this is
what we also observe in our lab we
tested several interventions
it's much more common to observe
lifespan extension in males than in
females so and and here is again this is
kind of the same conclusion
so these these findings are like yeah
really fascinating and yeah reinforce
the idea that early development is very
sensitive but i guess also
people could come across this literature
and also you know who are going through
pregnancy and start to you know maybe
worry about these things or
like how would you ever see
um or not see this information ever kind
of translating through to
interfering and early development
yeah so we are thinking about it
actually one idea be kind of exploring
whether interventions can be tested
early in life so we could subject
potentially
mice to some interventions and test time
during the first like 30 days for
example by using the machine clocks
portfolio in the growth
and this could be a potential screen
so instead of just waiting for the
entire life or for example treating old
animals because we need old animals for
that
but again so i think there are you know
so-called two types of uh interference
so and uh the kind of delay growth uh
may may not be associated with this
extension of life's lifespan but at
least
you know it would be more likely to
extend lifespan so i think it may be a
good idea to test
so we haven't done if we haven't done it
but i know some people in c elegans they
they tested this idea it seems to work
as well
so and of course now in flies and daphne
and mice so it seems like a general idea
so i think it would be a useful tool
actually
in the future
yeah be really interesting to see that
research um so like we've spoken about
intervening at early stage of life but
also there's a lot of research looking
at trying to um
like
use uh regenerative medicine or
rejuvenation technologies later in life
to help alleviate different
age-associated diseases and so just
wondering like to you what do you think
are the main
or like most promising strategies in
terms of rejuvenative approaches
oh i don't know
i mean
i mean the we
really don't understand what
rejuvenation means actually
so
like even the clocks uh
the kind of aging clocks all of the
clocks have been developed so far they
are aging clocks so they quantify
uh the direction from the young to the
old state
whether they would work in the opposite
direction
actually it's unclear it's it's
commonly used and so we use of course as
well and we kind of assume that if we
subject a system biological system like
cells or mice to some treatment and
observe a decreased biological age we
assume it's rejuvenation
i think there's one component of that is
rejuvenation but not
not the entire kind of response so
what i what i'm thinking is that we need
to develop
um clocks that would be
more tuned to
to test for rejuvenation so some kind of
rejuvenation plugs
such plugs do not exist yet
and because uh when we look uh and we
kind of think about the aging process
and quantify it
this clocks would necessarily be a
composite kind of
composite clocks uh
some changes each of the changes would
be
would be damaging would be
uh through aging some would be neutral
changes but they still could quantify
the asian processes and some would be
adaptive like we call them adaptive or
protective changes that uh that are
activated in response to
age agency changes like the kind of the
system finds a new homeostatic state in
a way
so they could still quantify aging but
they would have nothing to do with
rejuvenation
so i sometimes give this
a metaphor
of using um
adaptive changes in the form of like a
glasses or hearing aid or like a working
cane some some other features and we
could develop potentially a clock based
on this uh you maybe
collect uh parameters maybe 10 or 20
parameters like that and give away to
each parameter and quantify each i think
it you know would be quite reasonable
accuracy
and then we would fire all of the
doctors there's no doctors no glasses no
hearing aid and based on this everybody
is rejuvenated because the the way but
it's not yeah so this means that uh
agency changes have many many features
and only some of them quantify truly
represent aging and therefore would
represent rejuvenation so when we apply
existing clocks then we see rejuvenation
there's a clearly there's component of
it but
he cannot be 100 sure because we don't
know the contribution
i don't know if it's
explained clearly or not but
anyway so we need a new generation of
machining clocks which are specific for
rejuvenation they simply do not exist
and i don't think anybody at least i
haven't heard people even kind of
conceiving this idea just kind of asking
a question that we need a different type
of club
and then
by using the slack we could we could
address
beta address rejuvenation
so clear rejuvenation is possible
because we know
this
developmental rejuvenation embryonic
rejuvenation you know human naka type
gene nation and
i suspect there will be some other types
as well
and we are working on it as well but i
think many many labs are working on it
uh and
we need a better understand better
quantify it and then
you know once it's done then we could
broaden up and develop screening
approaches and so on but we just don't
have essential tools yet for that
yeah that's super interesting and so one
question i was going to ask was how
would you like validate such a
rejuvenation clock but then i was
thinking we've just spoken about early
development in that early rejuvenation
process is that not something that we
could potentially use to develop a
rejuvenation clock or not yeah but you
see it goes back to the what we
discussed earlier like on the in the
essence of aging so
what do we mean by age so and uh if we
again so i may be wrong but this is my
thinking it's a damage right and so if
you focus on quantifying this uh
damage negative consequence of of
metabolism or being alive then we follow
aging therefore we could follow
rejuvenation as well based on this if we
are able to distinguish various agent
changes what i don't like is that there
are so many papers so many studies when
somebody just look in a particular gene
for example some metabolite and observe
okay that gene uh decreased this age
let's bring it back to the useful level
and call it rejuvenation to me it's
simply nonsense
we cannot be sure because we don't know
if that naturally changes negative
positive or neutral we just cannot say
anything
based on this we need to distinguish
which one is which
[Music]
and yeah so in general i i think uh
in the aging field we just need more
uh
kind of fundamental uh studies
kind of uh conceptual studies just kind
of trying trying to define the aging
process because ultimately this is
essence so many people claim that we
already know everything about uh aging
we just need to develop quickly
interventions i think this is also wrong
we need more fundamental studies we need
more funding into the basic biology of
aging
not really translational yet i mean
translation is also good i mean this
this may actually increase funding for
the field but we need basic work we need
to build the
foundation for the field which does not
exist
so yeah really well said
is it amazing that
you know i was at the conference two
years ago and there was a questionnaire
given about to define agent researchers
in the field and everybody gives a
different definition of aging so it's
just yeah it's just amazing
so we disagree at the very fundamental
level so we need to work on that and
really to try to find consensus so you
will
do some experiments to at least to
clarify this this basic basic problem
exactly you know that was really well
said and so um obviously yeah there is a
lot of research and i was just uh
wondering you've done some work on like
naked mole rats you've done work on
human cells is there any model organism
that you would love to work on or
think would really help us to address
some of these questions
yeah we were thinking of yeah about
other organisms over the years actually
i've worked with maybe
20 different organisms all the way from
bacteria kia
flies east we work on east actually in
the lab currently also it actually it's
very good model organisms
i really like it because single cell
eukaryote ages and so many things can be
done at a very basic level
but
we are focusing basically on mice
primarily mice
and uh a little bit of human make more
rats and east
this is our current uh there is one
ongoing project on axolotl as well so
and actually on xenopus yeah you're
right there is some that we work
we work on a
few cool oh yeah i guess athlesses would
be an interesting one to further
understand rejuvenation right because
they have like limb regeneration is that
correct
uh what um
axolotls they have a lot of lemon
generation
yeah you're right yeah so and
uh
do you want to address the question of
the relationship between uh regeneration
and rejuvenation that's another big
question in the field in my mind what's
the relationship between these two
it's still unresolved but i think there
are some good models for it
um
both both mammals but but things like
axolotl for example as well
cool um so i want to like shift gears
slightly to i guess maybe some more uh
older work now that you published about
selenium and selenium proteins
so could you firstly i guess introduce a
bit of background to selenium proteins
oh yeah
so i guess my lab is actually best known
for for the for the studies on selenium
yeah so we work on this for a long time
i started when i was a postdoc i was
working with this statman
and later with dolph hatfield at nih as
a postdoc studying
serena proteins and when i started my
lab the first question that we asked is
what's the number of cylinder proteins
in mammals because at that time
researchers tried to understand the
effects of dietary selenium through a
couple of known cylinder proteins but
there was
no understanding on the on the number of
these proteins and what they do
and so i had a very talented graduate
student uh in the lab gregory kruger
who developed a computational approach
we called it sick is search
sick is the it's rna structure in the
three prime mtr of silent protein genes
which kind of is needed to reprogram the
ribosome so that it uses uga codon which
is normally a stock codon
instead uses it to insert sediment
system so cylinder cysteine we call it
the 21st amino acid in the generic code
because it's encoded by uh by a codon so
it's a co-translational insertion of
ceramic system into protein and
so he developed this approach and we
were able to identify
genes
and we found that in the human there are
25 cell protein genes
like in the mouse 24 and actually
characterized many actually all computer
sequence generals like for example in
the flies there are three in c elegans
one it is zero
um
anyway uh
and
that paper was published 19 years ago
it's a
our most famous paper published in
science where we said that there are 25
humans here on protein genes and as of
today actually there are still 25 it
seems we haven't missed a single one and
all of them be predicted correctly
and and then they realize that
ceremony cysteine is always located in
the active site of style accidentally
lactases or
ketogenesis where like analogous to
those which have cysteine
and it does some kind of
redux catalysis
uh and the known examples are you know
thyridox reductase for example a protein
that reduces steroidaxion which is the
main
protein that controls uh the reduced
state of cysteines in proteins in in the
cell and there is a protein called
methionines of oxide reductase which
reduce reduces oxidatively damaged
methanol residues
there is a favorite proteins called uh
thyroid hormone dehydrinase
uh there are three such enzymes which
activate and activate thyroid hormone
but it's but it's all it's a reductive
dehydration uh process so it's always
redux for good glutathione peroxidase so
we have this common feature so that's
how i realized okay i actually in the
redux biology area so we expanded
and reduced biology and
i
was actually i'm still
i have this title director of the center
for redux medicine for that reason
and then
and then because of this redux uh you
know i somehow
you know uh moved to the aging field
that was a always like natural natural
transition from selenium to redux to
aging
i
it was never a change like a dramatic
change it's kind of just almost like a
flow
but once we
uh
started studying aging it's just so
interesting
so fundamental it's actually very hard
to convince people to study anything
else once they kind of
taste what this is
it's just yeah
it's the most interesting so
yeah that's how it happened but we still
continue working on selenium trying to
understand over the years we for example
published many papers on identifying
genes which are involved in cellular
system biosynthesis actually it was only
resolved
about 15 years ago
when
we identified a couple of genes and then
experimentally uh it was uh
kind of the pathway was reconstituted in
the lab of dog hatfield at an age
it's actually interesting that celine
cystine is built on the trna uh the
there's a certain cystine trna initially
isolated
then syrian is phosphorylated and then
cellular cysteine is built on that trna
and then inserted into protein so if you
for example feed animals with cellular
sustained like a free amino acid
actually would need to be degraded to
selenite and rebuild on the trna only
then it can be inserted
and the functions of many syrian
proteins are still unknown
we identified some of them over the
years and um but many of them yeah
but it's always relaxed it seems like
redux is a common theme
so
yeah i think it's really fascinating
yeah biochemistry especially
with like how it's incorporated into the
amino acid in the first place given that
uga as you say it's a stop codon which
would basically stop protein production
so um i guess one i read a paper
recently about
celino protein p and i believe that's
the p stands or maybe it doesn't stand
for it but because it's in the blood
plasma and so it's uh
okay cool um and i think it i guess it
relates to more like systemic signaling
and also maybe influences neurogenesis
in the brain and so
i do know most of the story or
yeah i mean
it's a it's a very interesting protein
uh yeah it's primarily synthesized in
the liver uh in humans it has 10
cylinder cysteine residues that's the
only protein which has more than one and
the reason is that
it has a certain system rich
kind of tail uh this is the way to
deliver selenium from from the liver
where this protein is made to peripheral
tissues
and then the protein is degraded there
and and then cellular cysteine is used
for biosynthesis of cyanoproteins
uh
there are
examples of cell protein p in some
organisms with just one cell in a system
residue in human 10
but there's one in in in in oyster for
example in certain oysters which has
more than 100 cylinder system residues
in the property
yeah so no it's very interesting
um yeah
we do not really
we have a few papers on that protein but
it's not our major target
so but there are some other labs that
work on it
cool so the idea is like so we only get
selenium from our diets and so i guess
it's like broken down on delivery and
that's why it's selenium protein peas
mainly synthesize that to then i guess
deliver it to other tissues that then
needs this like different selenium
proteins for redox reactions
i would say yes but i would say that the
major implication of our work is that
because we know a full set of selena
proteins
we could explain why selenium is needed
it's it's only needed for the function
of these 25 proteins and that's it so
this is the difference for example
between selenium and many other trace
elements like for example zinc
i mean there are hundreds of proteins
which utilize zinc but we actually don't
know the number for sure like iron or in
molybdenum it's not fully clear like how
many proteins actually exist that
utilize a particular trace element in
the case of selenium it's very clear
because we
have this particular rna structure in
the three prime meter and and so so we
clearly know and so therefore we could
fully explain uh selenium selenium is of
course is an essential trace element if
you look in the multivitamin mixtures
then you always see selenium there but
you know along with other vitamins and
elements and the reason is because of
these 25 proteins and also it makes a
very convenient tool because we could
manipulate selenium in the diet like in
mice we often use the selenium deficient
diet oscillating with each time and
therefore we could manipulate the
expression of various proteins in the
targeted way there's a hierarchy for
example like brain and testis they have
the prior high priority for selenium so
even on the selenium deficiency brain
selenium level is constant whereas the
liver may lose up to 999 percent of
selenium because it's utilized for other
organs
um
oxidant protein p is synthesized and
kind of selenium is sent to other places
yeah and then this in this in the cell
there is a hierarchy some proteins are
more important it is in the cell for
example proteins like thyroidox
or glutathione percentage four which is
now is a very famous protein because of
ferrotosis it's a key protein it's a new
new form of cell death uh and uh the
most important protein in in this
pathway is called gpx4 phospholipid
hydroxyl glutathione oxidase
and uh it's a it's dependent on selenium
so that's why celine was also needed to
protect against theraptosis actually
yeah that's really interesting to hear
about uh selenium and so i feel like
we've covered like lots of different
topics um but are there any other areas
i guess of like aging research that you
also think are either interesting but
you want to study for like or you feel
like we need more understanding such as
like the gut microbiome for example
oh yeah got my uh there are so many
interesting areas
in the asian field many many interesting
topics gut microbiome is very
interesting as well
we
work a little bit but not not really
it's not a major target uh let's say it
would be very interesting uh um
i i don't know i'd be interested in many
questions for example
uh
when we rejuvenate let's say the
originate organism uh
this would probably mean that it would
be a rejuvenation of particular cells or
maybe if you replace an organ
it would be a rejuvenation of that organ
let's say if you replace like a old
liver with the young liver yeah how
would it affect the age of the entire
organism
so if one tissue is younger than the
other because presumably they would
interact
so
yeah so that's why we interested
interested in parabiosis model because
that's actually another very clear
example of rejuvenation actually this is
probably the most dramatic that we have
observed so far
so when we connect um we have a paper in
in by archive when the um it's a
collaboration with g white and duke when
we connect young and all for a longer
period like three months
and then separate them and follow for
another few months we observe that old
mice are still in the rejuvenated state
they're still younger and they also live
longer as well
so
what what is that mechanism so and what
is the contribution of various factors
is it uh access to the young organs or
its blood cells so plasma and what's the
results relative contribution of all
these features
and we have a collaboration on some um
studies to
replace or add organs for example that's
another very very cool topic in which we
also
address this kind of fundamental
features in the aging space how like
various aging modalities they interact
with one another if you see in the
organism
there are many many interesting
questions i would say it's a really cool
area so
yeah just also very exciting to be in
the field when there are so many new
tools available which you cannot i'm
kind of jealous to young scientists
because i wish we could we could have
these tools earlier if you could use
them but now it's just great to be
that's why they're so interesting all
these companies and
philanthropy and just so on because i
think people realize there's a potential
here in the field
yeah for sure and like speaking of i
guess like younger scientists you've had
a really incredible career so far and
published lots of really awesome work i
was just wondering do you have any
advice for i guess younger scientists or
anyone listening who yeah advice for
either conducting research or uh beyond
that
i don't know i mean uh
like my case it's n1 in the command so
there's no statistics here whatever i
can say it would be you know
it worked in my case i can say that i i
never had any strategy i just loved
science so and i
i like the work and when you like
something you just work on it because
it's your
work and it's your hobby and it's your
way of life it's all the same
you go to sleep and you think about your
scientific program or you travel you
think about it and it's more interesting
i don't know watching movies or like
playing games
you know just incomparably less
interesting so
so and then when you think about it you
focused on this you do it you tend to do
it well and everything else just
somehow happens by itself
so that's what
happened in me in my life so i just
followed what i liked and everything
else kind of worked out
by itself
so i i don't know
but it may be a bad example because
people always think okay they need to
have some build networks or some be on
certain social media or not twitter
whatever podcasts i don't know but i
don't know if it's good or not i think
ultimately there are many ways
we just need to enjoy what we like
what we do
and
and hopefully everything will work out
no i completely agree you know i think
having done it
passion is definitely important um yeah
i'm enjoying every day of it that's all
well that's that's all we want to hear
so i mean i say thank you for dean again
for yeah coming onto the show today it's
just been a really intriguing
conversation and i'm sure it's probably
sparked like many ideas into my viewers
minds it definitely has like given me
some uh interesting things to think
about so i'm just really grateful for to
you for taking the time to speak with me
yeah
thank you very much for inviting me to
your show
so it's really a pleasure and honor to
to discuss this with you
thank you very much thank you
so i hope you've learned something in
this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you